wenn dieses Video in Gamer Strike
bekommt dann nur weil sie draußen so
laut Musik spielen das hört sich an als
ob da draußen Festival spielt
hallo Leute hier sieht eure Meinung und
willkommen zu diesem neuen
adventskalender auspackvideo heute gibt
es mal wieder keinen richtigen
Adventskalender sondern die Industrie
hat
sich überlegt
wie Taschen ziehen
kann Kalender Deko für meine Karriere
kann ich auf jeden Fall hoffen dass sie
damit weitermachen und das nächsten oder
übernächsten Jahr jede Firma ihren
eigenen Halloween Kalender rausbringt
denn dann kann ich nämlich doppelt
auspacken und das wird niemals aufhören
oh mein Gott die Musik ist so laut es
kommt aus diesem Haus
und bevor jetzt denkt das Pokémon mich
bezahlt hat um über diesen
Adventskalender zu sprechen dieses
Videos nicht gespannt und jetzt alle
zusammen dieses Video ist nicht
gesprochen
mein Gott es war ein bisschen die
Melodie von this is Halloween bestes
Halloween
okay also ja ich habe dieses
wunderschöne Ding im Internet gefunden
das ist so ein Ort da findet man
eigentlich alles was man so sucht
niedliches Plüschkissen hat das Aussehen
einer schwarzen Katze genommen
und dachte mir neben dem Harry Potter
Halloween Kalender probieren wir auch
noch mal den aus und der sieht
der sieht so aus wie man sich so ein
Halloween Kalender vorstellt Leute
Pikachu hat einen Hexenhut auf und
kleiner fun fact ich habe bei festem
flauschig gehört das Pokémon das
erfolgreichste Franchise aller Zeiten
ist okay was haben wir hier also es ist
eine ganz schlichter Kalender und die
gewonnen haben Halloween stuff ich bin
großer Pokémon Fan ich habe als Kind
viel Pokémon gespielt ich habe mir jetzt
auch als Erwachsene die auf der Switch
dieses Legends oder so geholt wo man
halt wirklich den Pokéball plötzlich
selber werfen konnte und dann so sammeln
konnte und das habe ich wieder für ein
paar Wochen so richtig hart gesuchtet
dann war es raus aus meinem Leben
und was erwartet uns in diesem tollen
Pokémon Halloween Adventskalender was
ist denn das dann für ein Kalender
steht hier enthält 13 Geschenke
Countdown Halloween Countdown Kalender
die haben auch 13 Türchen ich sag's euch
halloween-kalender werden das nächste
Ding sein wir nehmen Harry Potter
Halloween Kalender am 19 müsste man
anfangen die Türchen aufzumachen und
dann hat man am 31 das letzte Türchen
Bescheid ne und jetzt machen wir die
Dinger mal auf ach nee
nee lass mal ich habe schon auf
Instagram gesagt das sind jetzt sehr
viele Spielzeug Adventskalender das
liegt aber daran dass viele Firmen ihre
Adventskalender jetzt erst losschicken
und ich sie halt noch nicht auspacken
kann aber ich wollte jetzt schon mal
anfangen denn ich habe ja ein paar jetzt
ähneln sie sich nur sehr und ich hoffe
ihr denkt nicht dass dieses Jahr nur
Kinder Adventskalender kommt bin da
nicht so für wir sind nicht so ich hoffe
ich kenne alle Pokémon die hier drin
sind aber ich bin auch nicht so gut
darin zusammen Türchen Nummer 1
gruselig das kriegt man ja richtig gut
raus toller Kalender
ey wieder ne ich glaube das ist für
kleine Kinder Hände gedacht aber
so dicke Wurstfinger habe ich jetzt auch
nicht
oh mein
Gott das war eine schwere Geburt also
wir haben hier ganz sicher was es ist
dieser Kollege sieht natürlich aus wie
Pikachu ist das Pikachu Gespenster
Kostüm Pikachu den sieht man auch hier
ich finde den für Halloween natürlich
super passend schreibt gerne mal in die
Kommentare ob es den wirklich gibt
machen wir mal weiter mit Türchen Nummer
zwei das wird sich schon alles klären
puh das hier kenne ich natürlich das ist
Evoli das sich als Hexe verkleidet hat
oh mein Gott mist das schon richtig süß
dieser Kalender richtet sich eindeutig
an Sammler und an Kindern aber es ist
super cute also ich finde es mega sieht
man hier die kleinen Freunde wie die
zusammenstehen oder kann man durch
spielen und Happy Halloween beginnt
heute um die Häuser wenn Kinder dieses
Jahr an Halloween auch bei mir klingeln
aber immer nur so ganz kleine Kinder
die kleinsten Kinder aus dem Haus
klingeln immer und die sind so drei vier
aber ich könnte ja dieses Jahr dann so
kleine Halloween Pokémon Figuren so mit
in den Beutel reinpacken das wäre mega
cool ich habe eine gute Idee ich gebe
ich einfach online meine Adresse frei
und dann könnt ihr mit euren Kindern zu
mir kommen dann bekommen Sie diese
Figuren lasst uns darüber noch mal ein
bisschen mehr nachdenken
definitiv nein Türchen Nummer 3 in
Tschechien Nummer drei befindet sich ah
ja klar habe ich so vor der Kanten crazy
3D Kürbis
den kannst du dann zu deinem Halloween
Pokémon tun ich sage euch wie es ist als
Kind Handys wahrscheinlich geliebt
eigentlich müsste ich wirklich Halloween
mehr auf meinem Kanal ausschlachten weil
ich liebe diesen Feiertag genauso wir
machen auch wie letztes Jahr eine
Halloween Party bei uns
und da schreibe ich auch einfach meine
Adresse in die Infobox und könnt ihr
Kommen ne oh nee dich kenne ich gar
nicht ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht ob hier
an diesem Pokémon irgendwas Halloween
mäßiges sein sollte bitte Stellung
beziehen zu diesem Pokémon seiner vollen
Pracht gibt es ein Pokémon was eine
Kerze ist also mittlerweile haben Leute
ein bisschen normal
ah schon wieder was aus Pappe jetzt
gibt's hier wieder das komplizierte
zusammensteckspiel ein Haufen
Süßigkeiten weil man sich da Süßigkeiten
holt na klar wollen wir vielleicht auch
wissen wie viel der gekostet hat
bevor wir hier ganz objektiv die Pokémon
Figuren bewerten 35 Euro der Playmobil
Adventskalender hat 25 € gekostet und da
waren Backofen dabei also Backofen drin
weil ich so gerne backe 35 € und für 13
Türchen 35 € für 13 Türchen ich weiß
nicht so Leute der sechste eigentlich
Nikolaus aber hier ein ganz normaler Tag
die haben alle so einen Schimmer
alle so ein
holoartigen Schimmer aber vielleicht
stehen die Leute einfach mittlerweile so
krass auf Holo bei ihren Pokémon wow
kenne ich auch nicht hast du irgendwas
halloweenmäßiges an dir nein einmal kurz
zu Demonstration
er kann nicht stehen die können wir doch
nicht erzählen dass diese Pokémon immer
so stehen muss und wenn ja dann tut es
mir leid boah ist das ätzend oh macht
mich das aggressiv oh ist das nervig ich
bin ich bin enttäuscht ich kann es noch
nicht ich will den noch nicht ne 35 €
und dann steht das nicht mal das Ding
aber natürlich die Nummer 7 wird viel
besser ach ja guck mal da den Kenny doch
falls ich meinen Namen falsch sage ne
sorry dieses Zubat es ist super oder
sogar kann stehen aber diese Katze nicht
was macht mich so aggressiv
[Musik]
Nummer 8 ist leer wahrscheinlich ihre
durchgerutscht aber bei so einem
Kalender sollte nicht durchrutschen leer
leer
also ich finde sehr toll ne jetzt wieder
die neuen sehr großen präsent aber
dieser Kalender
ich kann nicht mehr so viel sagen ich
bin ein bisschen sprachlos gerade eine
Lampe
Nummer 10
keine Ahnung Knochen Knochen knochenmon
der passt ah na klar zu was passt ja
auch zu Halloween als so ein Fledermaus
ist und Fledermaus ist Halloween der
hier der
knochenknochenmann das passt natürlich
auch mit seinem skelett-artigen und
Katzen schwarze Katze passt aha und halt
Evoli mit dem Hut ne Nummer 11
noch ein paar Kürbis zum Aufstellen toll
so zwei haben wir noch
Nummer 12 all das süß Schiggy und
Schiggy hat so ein kleines Kästchen mit
Süßigkeiten dabei aber Schiggy ist
irgendwie ganz komisch Schiggy hat so
Trecker auf dem Gesicht und an der Pfote
sieht so aus als ob das schon mal mit
jemandem gespielt hat und jetzt sind wir
schon beim letzten Türchen
es zu seinem
Kalender okay zum 13 Türchen und was
gruseliges bitte drin sein oh
wie sehen die schon sehr mitgenommen aus
wir haben Pikachu toll toll mit dem
Kürbis im Kopf das ist tatsächlich sehr
witzig und wo ist jetzt unser Adam für
die Nummer 8 wie konnte ich das
übersehen kandierte Äpfel oh dazu muss
ich ein Video machen das muss ich mir
gleich mal aufschreiben in Amerika haben
sie dieses kandierte äpfelgame auf ein
ganz anderes Level gebracht da gibt's ja
dann zu Halloween und so allgemein
glaube ich auch grüne Äpfel in Karamell
getunkt und mit Nüssen irgendwie
drumherum
treat and Helling Goodies in Karamell
getunkt oh Gott wie geil die haben wir
noch mal unser Türchen Nummer acht
schöne karamelläpfel toll schokoläpfel
irgendwas Äpfel die Macht dieses Jahr
auch meine Halloween Party das muss ich
ein Feedback geben kann ich heute mal
das Feedback einfach streichen
wir haben hier eine tolle Armee an süßen
Halloween Pokémon
einer der nichts stehen möchte und dann
haben wir so ein bisschen Halloween Kram
an dem sie so rumstehen 35 Euro
ich meine es ist eine Sonderedition und
die Kosten wahrscheinlich immer ein
bisschen mehr denn wann hat Pikachu
schon mal so einen süßen Kürbis auf dem
Kopf dafür muss man draufzahlen aber der
hat mir die Laune einfach zu sehr
verdorben alles Gute was ich über diesen
Kalender sagen hätte wollen
das ist so dieser EMP Moment
ich bin jetzt ehrlich das ist ein
beschissenes 24 Türchen diese Figuren
haben wir beim 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 Figuren
die Pappe zähle ich jetzt hier mal nicht
mit das ist Pappe 35 € durch 8 Figuren
sind 4 €
38 profigur ich glaube das ist schon
okay nein es ist nicht doch schreibt mir
doch gerne eure Meinung mal in den
Kommentaren vielleicht kennt ihr euch ja
in dieser Szene besser aus wenn wir das
Gefühl dass das so ein guter Art ist
Leuten noch ein bisschen Geld aus der
Tasche zu ziehen
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten Video
ich freue mich schon da drauf und Happy
Halloween freut Euch auf meine Halloween
Videos ich mache Halloween Videos ich
habe Bock auf Halloween Videos auch wenn
das niemand sehen möchte aber ein paar
von euch schon oder danke tschüss